歡迎收看趙華
阿倫說
我是趙華
我是艾倫
大家有看到了嗎
沒錯
噔噔噔
今天雖然不是史上最大跌點
但是今天的體感超級爛
沒錯
嗯
又是一個上市規加起來
百家跌停的行情
是
我今天有去看一下喔
你知道上漲的加速
上市規加起來多少嗎
10家
沒有那麼過分
上漲啦
上漲嗎
150家
差不多
對
我感覺的
2000家都是下跌的
是
加薪貴是不是
對 非常辛苦的一個行情
因為今天的話
不但在季線下
而且是季線下的大黑K
我們幾乎
以前碰到季線就上去了
所以今天看起來是一個
我們很久沒有看過的一個狀況
是 這個
只能說這個物業偏棚連漏雨
是
突然繞了一下方言
沒有 因為現在的行情
其實已經很脆弱了
但是昨天突然連續出現了
三個有關半導體
可能大家解讀為利空的新聞
所以帶動了整個行情
今天用完那個韓國股市
真的是太辛苦了
韓國股市跌了10個百分點
沒錯
但是有一個好事是什麼呢
我們上次也有錄
在華安倫的時候說
拿出這個紙箱
可是我跟安倫都不記得
那時候到底發生什麼事了
所以稅公園的朋友
我們是有機會再回來的
因為我們會忘記多頭會回來
好 非常有信心
我們一定要相信
現在的基本面依舊是好的
但我們寫了一個五言絕句
利空出不進
撈底又被套
是買還是賣 四步驟處理
好 我們今天就直接切入重點
直接跟大家講
到底發生什麼事情
該怎麼處理 到底有哪一些鬼故事
到底是真的還是破解
好 我們先看一下
我們先看一下左邊這邊
我們先看一下結果是什麼
再來講原因
韓國股市呢其實這一根
其實我覺得很可惜
因為它這裡已經兩週的時間
在這邊努力做打底
去槓桿了嘛 錢都
我跟你說上禮拜我們才講說
他們也很猛
本來八月要上路的去槓桿
七月底就先上路
沒錯啊
結果今天說
還有後面喔
還會再繼續限制
你們買槓桿型的ETF喔
沒有錯
所以他們其實很積極
在做這件事情
那其實這件事情出來之後
你看這邊跌下來
他們的槓桿也一定有
相對減碼了很多
但在這種狀態之下
它還是可以破底之後
然後跌 單日跌10%
今天又有20分鐘暫停交易
對 所以你看這個利空到底多大
再來另外一個就是廢半
廢半其實這一次
他們還是有守住前滴的
那重點是誰沒守住
重點是我們台灣股市沒守住了
我們的42K這邊的支撐區有沒有
這一個平台全破了
今天跌破了
難怪那麼不舒服
那什麼事情呢
三大利空這個藏心存儲
還有這個DUV
其實我覺得這件事情是一個
最莫名其妙的一件事情
人家要研發就讓他研發
對啊 然後再來另外就揮打
砸2500億體那個OpenAI
我們等一下每一頁都會特別去講
我們先看結果
結果就是韓國股市今天很辛苦
帶動我們台灣股市
日本股市 今天亞洲股市
整體的跌點跟體感都非常的差
好 那我們來看一下
第一個就是長新存儲
長新存儲到底發生什麼事情
其實在前面一陣子就
長新存儲都會三不五時冒出來一下
然後南亞科就會跌停
然後因為它會做DDR
所以我們的南亞科就會跌
對 然後就是
其實HBM不受影響
DDR才會受影響
這次HBM也受不了了
沒錯 那我們來看一下
其實長青存儲是全球第四大的一個
記憶體的公司
那這間公司為什麼近期站在浪頭上
就是因為它上市了
那上市了它就可以幹嘛
市場是這樣解讀的
它上市了之後就會有更多資金
就可以跟大家拿錢
對 拿錢要幹嘛 要擴廠
像在上海在合肥要新界兩座工廠
那目前還有第三座
那預計產能呢
2030年會超過美光
那就是變第三名了
然後全球DRAM市站呢
在2028年會攀升到18%
所以這間市場呢
是在擔心這件事情
它現在在這裡 美光在這裡
它會超過美光耶
對啊 會把它吃掉耶
對 所以大家會擔心的
就是這件事情嘛
然後尤其呢
大家會覺得說
其實為什麼
藏心存儲這麼出來之後
HBM可能會遇到的一個狀況
就是供給大家的需求
然後再來另外一個
就是他們做出來的東西
會比較便宜
那大家就擔心說
那這樣子是不是整個HBM或記憶體
得一個長線的這個大多頭
就會告一段落
那這個告一段落過程中
當然影響最大的就是誰
當然就是韓國股市
因為三星跟海力士
占他們全值超過五成
好再來看另外就是這個
這個我就覺得最莫名其妙
昨天艾斯摩爾就突然大跌
就這樣跌了
艾斯摩爾你可以做EUV好嗎
對啊 你做DUV而已
你可以做EUV
人家是做DUV
好我們來看一下
這邊呢
目前這間公司不知道叫什麼名字
因為未居民
但是他有說是有官方扶持背景的企業
大家可能都很擔心這件事
對 因為我來上網找
他真的都不知道是哪一間
那目前他說
2025年可以生產5台
2027年可以到20台
那目前來說
整個零件全部都是國產化的
除了一些精密零件來自日本
那這個就是他們認為
就是哎呦
中國的技術好像追上來了
不過他們這個
就像你講的找不到名字之外
發布的人也不知道是什麼用心
沒錯
發布在一個科技平台上面
對 可是呢
確實就是因為這件事情
導致昨天半導體設備廠
美國的全部都在跌
埃斯莫爾龍頭嘛
跌5% 柯林 4% 硬材
Nikon還有Canon
全部都是受不了了
其實我也不太懂為什麼
反正大家市場很緊張
好 我覺得現在真的是
利空的反應比較大
因為昨天也有傳出一個事情
是有人寫說
太陽又有電要漲價
據說也不是真的
但是利多不發酵
但利空就馬上發酵
沒錯
可是大家忍進去思考
首先第一個這是DUV
再來第二個
它是賣中國的廠商
對啊 自產自銷
沒錯 那你說美國這個
它有可能會賣到美國去嗎
那我覺得不太可能
好 那再來另外一個
就是這件事情
揮答雜錢 擔保OpenAI
可以有2500億的融資
不過揮答成為全世界AI債主
這件事情也不是第一次在聊了
不過昨天晚上揮答的債信的CDS
是有微微的往上跑了
大家安心說
你建那麼多錢出去後來
將來會不會違約
或是升息以後
你的舉債成本會變得更有壓力
沒有錯
市場在質疑呢
就是質疑兩塊
現在其實整個華爾街外資
最擔心的
不是你有沒有賺錢
而是你的資本支出
到底為什麼要一直增加
增加這麼多
不能回收
你又一直舉債之類的
沒錯
從台積電就看得出來
Google也是一樣
那回答這一次也是一樣
這是第一個問題
就是你一直砸錢
到底什麼時候可以回來
到底賺不賺得回來
再來第二個呢
就是大家市場在質疑
这个需求是被养出来的
为什么
因为挥达是生产者
但是他同时也是金主
我今天要卖东西给你OpenAI
然后我又给你OpenAI钱要干嘛
跟我挥达买晶片
所以这个会不会是
自己做成的一个涌动机
就是10月去年在讲的涌动机
OpenAI的涌动机
没错
我下单给你这样
对所以这个就是一个
非常奇怪的状态
我钱丢给你
然后你再回来跟我买GPU
这个是不是就是财务上的
美化的状态
所以我觉得这件事情
確實是值得去深思的
但是目前來說
我回答有說出來
投入的資金
只佔客戶整體募資的需求
一小部分
那相關的投資
除了帶動業務
也有機會創造
實際的投資報酬
那這些東西
全部這三個新聞
全部都是跟半導體有關
所以昨天的半導體的廢伴
跌幅也最重
那我們台灣股市
昨天的跌幅其實也不輕
對
所以又再反映到
今天跟著韓國股市
一起再走回落
所以整體的體感
就會非常的差
好 那非常的差
那我們今天這一根到底發生什麼事情
我們今天最後跌了2000點
那2000點呢
跟前面這個台積電隔天的這個黑K
3000點相比
也少了1000點
但是因為眼睛未接下過來了
而且破了季線後的大黑K
而且昨天還受了一個腳
讓你以為今天有機會反彈
昨天那個真的是
我覺得
對不對
拉尾盤
650點
讓你以為今天又有好日子過
結果沒有
而且昨天下午每股的電子期
還先往上走
對
太過分 今天全部
沒了
你說跌破昨天低點就算了
沒有啊 他是連這個前面的
禮拜一的低點都跌破了
那跌破過程中
其實大家就還是要注意啦
我們一直有在強調嘛
你到底什麼時候可以積極的買
積極的買的定義是
真的可以把自己的部位放得大
那第一個呢
大紅K要過下降趨勢線
這我們大概講兩週的時間
結果都沒有
沒錯 那再來第二個是什麼
就是開低走高爆量大
大紅K 大黑K 下引線
那重點是量要夠大
那目前來說也沒有
那現階段呢
我們保持的策略就會是
如果你要買一檔
你覺得看好的股票
那可能就是分批買
必須把資金拆開
是的 下一段跟大家講
貴買就更辛苦
貴買今天跌了7%
接近7% 6.79%
貴買這邊我們之前說
你這個平台已經跌破了
對 400點要佔
400整數位置要佔回來
這邊有反彈過
但沒有站穩
然後沒有站穩
今天還破底
所以這個行情呢
也就依舊沿著一個
下降局勢在向下走回落
這已經快回到今年
三四月的那一個
大多頭的起漲點
所以這邊會有強支撐
同時也是年限的位置
那就只能看能不能撐住了
這個都是比較辛苦的手勢
大家要有耐心
好 因為如果就貴買來說的話
就是大家體感的來源
沒錯 因為如果你看這個台積電
雖然今天也PO一個小低
可是總體跌幅
總是比貴買好很多
沒錯 台積電這樣跌下來
大概10來1%
對 就跟大盤差不多了
對 貴買跌了超過兩成多了
大概2成3 2成4
那目前台積電
當然今天跌破平台
那季線也三天沒有
兩天沒有站穩
沒有 今天第一天而已
今天第一天而已
昨天有站上
所以台積電目前來說
也是一個蠻明確的
一個整理的結構
那也只能先看一下
台積電什麼時候
能夠不再破底
然後站回季線
或者說先把下降趨勢都站回來
我覺得才是轉問
那另外也是鴻海
鴻海前一陣子
這個ODM的走勢是非常強
因為偽創有這個
對 黃仁勳的加持
那不過今天呢
ODM也撑不住了
尾盘都有一个明确的回落
那不过鸿海呢
前低是还守住的
所以相对还是抗跌
那当然因为它前面跌很重了
那来到这个位置
239它前守好
那守好过程中
如果这边
我们这边其实有站回季线
所以现在下来走回测
这边如果能够守好
那能够再走一次反弹
这个颈线做突破
这也就会是WD
所以目前鸿海来说
我们就关心前低
能不能持续的守好
这边的话
你以前交过风险报酬比
应该也适用
对不对
再去测的时候
可以抓一个所谓的风暴笔
没错
所以如果想要在这边去做买进的
那记得230块
就会是你短线停存点
如果是想做价差
那鸿海你说长线投资
那我觉得基本面
应该不会有太多问题
所以今天是全治股的部分
帮大家讲清楚
那当然大家现在
已经想要问了
最大跌点那一天
可能都不见得想问
但现在想要问的是
怎么办呢
我手上偏偏就是热门的小型股
可是砍在今天就没有尊严
还有机会反弹吗
怎么都没有一个明确的反弹
最大涨点那天
看来现在变成了人道走
这些疑问
我们等一下的节目会
一一来帮您说
如何降低现在持股的压力
如何能够找到真正的止跌
转折
等一下来教了
好 講之前我們先看一下
7月的漲跌幅的前10名
7月其實還是有人漲
只是我們都沒有
7月其實有人跌很慘
大家手上都有
沒錯 我們看到漲的呢
台自備的很強
台宏 台宏自己很強
台宏自己很強
最近還是很強
然後再來台素集團
台素化 台化
但最近也回答了
那另外就是軍工股
這三個都軍工股
那紅字道比較特別連接器 金財這最近也是很熱門的一檔股再來看到碟幅大概分兩大族群我剛剛已經瞄了一下被動元件系列的
再來有什麼
LED系列的
大概就這樣來結束了
這個還國劇集團
國劇集團還有主動元件
漲價系列
那個啊 你的布
對 沒關係 不用看它
布很久以前就覺得
對 就比較辛苦
那這個是目前漲碟
你看這跌幅前10名
30名 第10名還有跌30%
所以你知道這個行情
就真的比較辛苦一點了
好 那既然辛苦的過程中
我們給大家幾個方向
高檔套勞不敢賣 怕坎低
怎麼辦
有錢想低接 但怕還沒觸底
再來一直殺低 又追高 背套
怎麼辦
真的 現在想要抄底就背套
沒錯 對 怎麼辦
再來呢
空手又怕錯過行情
但又不敢買 怎麼辦
真的啊 難得又跌到際線下了
之前不是告訴我們說
有大回答我叫all in嗎
沒錯 現在不敢不敢pass了
所以說怎麼樣
今天這個都是大家可能
心裡有的問題
就是在心裡面的murmur
被放出來了
我們現在解讀一個
高檔套牢不敢賣
怕砍在最低點
對啊 那怎麼辦
怎麼辦
首先你要去辨辨
那個折凳幫我拿進來一下
我還沒有開始耶
還沒開始
我還沒有說怎麼辦怎麼辦
這樣好不好
還算有克制啦
OK
來我們要先辨別的就是什麼
回歸到基本面了
到底這個個股
是有沒有真的有基本面
我不知道
我現在真的不確定
首先你要確定
譬如說台積電
那個聯電
聯發科
這些可能大家
就應該確定
它會有實質的獲利的EPS
它會有競爭的壁壘
那長線的成長是有軌道的
那這個我覺得
就可以稍微先去
把它留在先不砍這一塊
那先砍的要先砍什麼
就是假題材
譬如說靠題材拉抬的
那可能缺乏基本面支撐的
那如果在大反反彈的時候
資金一定會先往這一塊線去做進場
那這個等要漲高了之後
大家才會開始炒題材股
大家自己去看六月營收
根本就沒有成長的
我覺得那個就是優先先列入這裡
不一定題材是假的
但是它的營收跟不上
可能還沒有放出來
這樣講可能比較具體一點
是的 好那再來
非基優股的就是強調
你反彈的過程中
或者说技术性性反弹的时候
先分批抽回资金
对啦 我觉得反弹
大家有压力的人
拿一点钱回来吗
没错 比如说新兴确实嘛
也是就算是有增价值的个股
那目前来到这个位置
你说它是不是一个空方的结构
那我必须说
它还真的是空方结构
对 可是呢
如果你现在假设一个状况
你现在手上呢
譬如说你只剩下新兴
跟某某个股
剩两档到三档
那这些个股
在你的总资金比例呢
不到三成
可是呢我可能
新兴我买在这个地方
那我会建议像你这种有增基本面
然后你持股又不至于要睡不着的
我觉得是可以hold看看的
因为你来到这个地方
已经来到这个位置了
星星啊 这股价
这个基本面没有不好嘛
是筹码 筹码也还在想办法嘛
跟技术面上的转弱嘛
那我觉得这个就可以等
可是如果你说我今天持股
100万
比如说我1000万
我已经700万了
那700万里面我包含一档
有一档星星
那这个时候我觉得我睡不着
因为辛苦钱嘛
我赚这么多钱
那这个时候我建议就降下来
比如说降到500万以下
400万 300万以下
降到你不会睡不着的状态
那这个是为了让自己舒服去降的
那不然的话剩下就是看基本面
要不要去做一个减码的状态
好 所以高档套牢的朋友
看一下自己的压力
和辨别一下个股的价值面
没错
那这边的话是想低接
很容易接刀啊
现在应该不会鼓励大家
现在就猛然去接吧
但确实上礼拜一定有人接
有啦 最大的跌点出现就觉得
最大的跌跌出現囉
7月17點嘛
然後週一先再跌一下
週二千點反彈
所以這個時候大家一定就是
來了就是我們要等那一根
那可是呢等完這一根之後呢
我們舉聯發哥啦
那上去結果聯發哥今天
快要破底了
那怎麼辦
那我買了我買了這一根的
我買了這裡的
今天短線基本上又套牢
那跟大家講想低接啊
可以用一個分批進場的方式
這個呢就會是
比較偏左側的交易
第一筆你可以先做試探
第二笔去做确认
再来是做确立
也就是说第一笔的时候
它可能整个形态还是偏空的
但是你觉得它已经
来到一个初步止跌的状态
譬如说它底部不再破了
再来另外一个确立的双重底
我们刚比如说已经是这样子了
最好还是要打轿了
对 然后突破了高点
那这个地方
你可以把最后的金额加进去
也就是说呢
其实现在把一个习惯改掉就是
我原本可能一次进场到位
那改成分三次进场慢慢到位
而且不要说还在下跌过程
就想说我觉得今天会最低
没错
就贸然投入
其实还是要有一个
止跌的讯号出现
是的还是要记得
你手上还是要保留
大部位的现金
这个要大家稍微注意一下
好 那我们举联发科为例子
那再来另外一个就是
哎呀 这个追高杀低
因为精彩前面是强势股
但最近也一样跟着大盘杀下来了
没错
所以可能上去的时候觉得
我避险到强势股
是啊
就现在变弱势股了
没有错
因为我们要讲的实际是这一段
這一段 追上去的人
在整理嘛
那這個時候大跌嘛
結果行情好的時候
精彩確實嘛
那個時候也連續兩天都漲停板
那漲停板的時候
這就是底部碰月線轉牆的訊號
對啊 我做一個
你不能說追高啦
因為就是強勢股
本來就是動的
你要這樣子做
那個是下來的時候
哇 我直接連前面底點都破
那該怎麼辦
那這個時候呢
就要稍微記得一下
如果你是一檔
那可能是自己
可能是行情的問題
但是可能兩檔 三檔 四檔
那到時候你的心態
應該也會出現一些問題
心態崩
我是不是不會做股票
那請大家不要這樣子去質疑
因為現在這種行情
你不管買多
基本面多好的股票
全部都在跌
我就是不會做股票
對 所以大家不要這樣質疑自己
不要質疑自己
現階段就是要幹嘛
就是整個的大環境是不對的
那不對的是幹嘛
你就要PASS一下
你要設定交易的冷卻期
請暫停交易
請停止賣出
按一下
有一個這個訊號
没错 所以这边就稍微让自己的情绪
回来一点点
因为你现在已经有点非理性了
有的之前是FOMO
现在是已经不知道
到底还能不能买股票
会质疑自己
让自己的心态稍微正确一点
再回来看一下
量缩再布局
进场之后要设好停存点
重新再把自己的纪律
全部跟自己讲一次
然后再来去做操作
好 再来最后一个
就是空手观望
现在一个状态了
我满手现金
我空手观望
我这样也要急啊
这样也要那个
你看7月17日3000点嘛
对啊
然后礼拜二是不是大涨1500点
所以有的人会觉得说
我1500点没赚到
那1500点进场之后
结果又吃下来
所以会有这种状态嘛
所以其实人性是很难去hold住的
但其实这总过一句话就是
到底什么样叫做安全进场
或者是止跌讯号
没错 是的
所以給大家一個感覺
就是大家一方面
跌的時候不敢買
一方面你漲的時候
你會有FORMAL感
那到底要怎麼辦
簡單一點嘛
你就買一點
總資金的10%到20%
買入一些看好的
基本面紮實的
當市場上漲的時候
你會說什麼
好險我手上還有一些股票
對 那市場下跌的時候
我好險 還有可以再繼續買
對 你就是讓自己保持在場內
但你又可能只是
一半隻腳在裡面
你也不是全部栽進去
但你也不是在場外
所以這樣子的狀態之下
其實我覺得這件事情
比較針對的是
你情緒上的波動的
因為如果你沒有什麼情緒的
其實就等轉文再買
我覺得就沒什麼問題
那這邊呢
我們就舉例像滑星光
滑星光呢
前面這一陣子是先跌
那你等一下到這裡
你可以發現這邊底部開始出量
出量上空 對
可是大盤行情不好
可是它就一直漲
看起來好像只跌了
對啊 那怎麼辦
可是又感覺滑星光
好像基本面CPU
整個基本面還要花一段時間
可是呢
那確實股價最近連五紅連六紅
那怎麼辦 一樣嘛
可以佈局一點點
那這邊感受一下它的整個狀態
那確實形態如果越打越好
整個大盤轉穩它有沒有機會
CPU先做第一段的主流的族群
那這個我覺得是可以好好去參考思考的
所以今天這邊也幫大家做一些
其實我覺得最後一點主要處理的
是你自己的情緒
後面三點跟四點應該都處理情緒
那前面一兩點應該主要會比較偏向
實質上的操作行為
所以今天直接帮大家做一个
我觉得这应该是近期
不同的状态的人都会有的情绪
然后帮大家解读一下
好 总之就是先把心情定下来
如果持股非常高水位
已经睡不着的
自然是无论如何换一点现金
对不对
先不要去想说
这样砍很没有尊严
砍在阿呆股先降你的压力
但是如果手上刚好这段时间
换满现金的人
也不要全数离场
全数离场
如果今天真的来个大反弹
你又觉得很formal了
是
所以反而要先试一点单子
到你信任的股票上面
好 希望大家这段时间
因为行情真的是比较气氛差
可以平心尽气
需要今天所有图卡资料的话
也欢迎来一下
我们赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
我们会放在首页的提问栏
等一下的大来宾也会跟大家分享
他曾经在股灾的时候资产归零
可是这一次他有提到
不觉得跟上一次股灾是一样的问题
反而他现在看到的是
很多机会也是要把握诀窍来掌握
欢迎回到赵华
阿伦说
今天你到底在忙什么
今天早上看一看盘就关掉了
对
关掉
你不能买你也不能卖
对啊就看一下
哇这行情真的好惨
然后就没事了
那我问你
像因为今天很多人都有传续题跟我说
他觉得这个比上市跌2900多点体感还要烂
那你有这种感觉吗
我觉得有
因为一开始其实很多全职股
除了台积电台积电其实还好
可是很多全职股一开盘
其实就7 8 9%去了
对那后面中小型个股跟着补跌
最后连CPO这个最近比较强势的
它也升不住了
所以今天这个盘是就真的也只能
眼睁睁的看它这样子
对就空手看了
但是今天我们的来宾
他会觉得
大家真的不要在今天这么惊慌
就今天对他来说
以他的历程来说
就一个可能不是小蛋糕
一个小泡芙
小屑屑
因为什么大风大浪
什么机构没待过
我们先来欢迎他
就是我们也很崇拜的
新南股神威良哥
嗨 大家好
好 威良哥今天来接受
我们的专访
因为威良哥的资历
其实他待过
我们以前常常跟大家讲
他待过所谓的正期
他待过头信
对 头信
今天也是一个重点
所以很清楚想知道投信在做什麼
然後待投股是大老師喔
所以今天的風浪對你來說
真的叫做一顆小泡芙對不對
當然你必須要先經歷過破產
因為我其實剛加入股市的時候
剛好那一年真的是史上
非常強勁的大多頭
可能沒有像過去這半年一年這麼強
不過就是非常著名的
網路科技的崛起
1999到2000年
那時候真的買什麼賺什麼
最狂的时候都跟我身边的朋友说
我要赚的不是%数
而是倍数
这句话真的没有吹牛
因为我那时候最差的时候
大概剩一档是赚50几%
那是最差的时候
最差的
因为其他的全部都是翻倍
只是后来我觉得经历过
连续大概半年多的
怎么买怎么赚的过程
真的像极了像今年上半年的故事
真的好像
后来就会发生一件事情
就是市場開始有點反轉了不過當你在前面的半年多的時間是每逢拉回就买进每逢大跌就用力加码的这样的一个过程
其实人就会被养成多头惯性
我常说就是被多头市场宠坏了
所以当下跌的时候
一开始我们会觉得
这一次跟前面都是一样的
所以就有钱就继续加码
没钱呢
可能就放任也不管
等到真的跌了一段了
时间也这个
这个蛮明显的
这个经历了一段长时间的回挡
然后幅度呢
也慢慢的越拉越开
越跌越深的时候
回头才看到
我怎么离上面的高点
蛮远的了
才发现苗头不对
但是通常那时候
大概其实个股都已经
平均是跌三成到四成
不是跟现在很像吗
对
那通常在三成到四成的时候
也会陷入两难
那这时候到底要不要买
会不会砍大家再带一股
对
就會想要等反彈
那結果呢
可能沒有等到
像個樣的反彈之後
又下殺破敵
所以其實在網路科技那一波
所謂的泡沫破滅之後
很多科技股
尤其越是主流的
這個科技股
網路股
它其實真的不是腰斬
是跌到腳踝
因為光是大盤指數
10393跌到341
大概算你知道
差不多就是跌了七成
所以經歷過那一次的
震撼教育之後
我痛力思痛
最主要有两点修正
第一个我发现就是
所有的空头趋势
它一定是有机可循
它不会突然降临
那也不会呢
就是迅速的
就是演变成一个空头趋势
它一定是慢慢慢慢形成的
所以我们一定呢
可以从一些基本面的蛛丝马迹
找到线索
那第二件事情呢
从此我戒掉一个习惯
千万不要下跌就买
拉回就加码
那资金一定是要有策略性的
就算想要去抄底一些
认为超跌的便宜股票
也不要一口气就急着
把子弹全部用尽
好 所以这边的话
也浓缩有一个座右铭
对不对
买强不买弱
买高卖刚刚
我也希望可以做到
威良哥这样子
基本面决定股价的高度
筹码面来决定股价的速度
这些都在操作里面
其实说的可能简单
做起来并不是那么的容易
其实我觉得这两句话
可以把它浓缩一点
就是我们大部分的投资人
应该都很相信
股市投资说出来就是买低卖高
不过说实在话
在我自己投资的前期跟后期
那个绩效的转捩点
就是当我把买低卖高这四个字
丢到税子机碎掉之后
我从此开启了另外一扇窗
因为我发现
在这个有效率的市场里面
你不要怕买高
但是重点是
你要掌握的是
它未来有没有成长前景
买高能够让你卖更高
尤其我们绝大部分的人
都不是想在股市里面
当巴菲特的信徒
做价值投资
我们喜欢的是动能交易
我们喜欢的是价差操作
所以买高没关系
重点是要卖更高
但是这个如果你没有
把功夫练好的话
一线资格
有时候就会变成是一种
盲目的在最高点
才经常被割韭菜
所以其实待会儿我们会去提
你怎麼樣能夠買高賣更高
如果講太久再減掉
所以今天早上我做了什麼事情
我就把我的助理跟研究團隊找來
那我想要呢
把我對現在的行情的看法
從而到而跟他們再論述一次
那我想聽聽
大家對我的邏輯的想法是什麼
我其實不想要找人來做同溫層取暖
我想聽聽看有沒有人
跟我不一樣的看法
那我想要確定一件事情
因為我現在想做的策略
就是以靜自動
看起來是不作為
但是這個不作為呢
好像議題兩面
有點像是擺爛
不做任何動作
所以我們想要確認是
這是思考理性判斷之後的
不作為
而不是呢
只是因為被行情
壓垮了情緒之後
然後選擇逃避的擺爛
這個時候只要確認
基本面沒有改變的話
我覺得我們就可以
換一個視角去看
很多股票
是不是在風暴過後
它真的出現了
打折的甜甜價
因為剛剛我兩個有講到一句話
他說空頭如果來襲
或是像剛剛講到的
有點溫水煮青蛙對不對
每次下跌就覺得再去撿
一定會贏
它其實有機可循
可是這一次
你覺得不會像網路泡沫那樣
而是先定下心來
一定有邏輯論述
所以台股的跌跌不休
投資人該怎麼應對
跟那一次就不一樣了
你會覺得現在很多公司打折
反而是機會
為什麼要這樣想呢
因為大家一定現在
跟你講的一樣 好怕喔
好怕現在根本就空頭成形了
我還沉溺在跌下來
就可以剪的心情裡
其實說出來就是
像跟我們身邊的朋友
或者是比我們更資深的前輩
甚或是在電視機前面
才會看到那些產業大佬們
我們向他們取經
那為什麼呢
因為其實不久之前
台積的法術會
大家印象一定很深刻
所以當大跌的時候
如果你對未來的AI趨勢發展
产业前景
开始有一些疑虑的时候
到底是不是因为
被股价下跌影响的信心
那我觉得就回头
再把所谓的魏哲家
或者是黄仁勋
他们近期对产业的看法
我觉得可以重新再复习一次
同样道理我们可以把
目前手上套牢的个股
或者是暴跌的个股
它的基本面
它的研究报告
我们再从头再检视一次
其实就发现
最近股价真的是跌很深
有些已经出现腰斩
但是绝大部分的个股都没有出现
很明显的基本面被下修
绝大部分都没有
那甚至在这一两个月
很多市场杂音传出来的时候
我们还看到有一些个股
它的基本面其实是被上修的
那再者就是我认为
当然我们要有风险意识
不过呢
最好的风控
应该都是在平常就要做好
用个生活来举例
如果你有风险的意识
那你想要买保险
应该是在平常就买好
那一旦已经生病了
或是发生了突发的事情的时候
你想要买医疗险或意外险
一来根本可能买不到了
那二来就算买得到
我相信呢
那个保费会非常非常的贵
因为呢
你就必须要付出风险溢价
所以像今天早上也有人问我说
哇 觉得可能会下探4000点
现在要不要去放空台子
期货来做避险
他说会破4万点大关
对不对 是这个意思
對 就是有沒有可能會破到4萬點
那要不要去買台紙期貨
去放空台紙期貨 做避險
針對這個部分我會覺得
像過去台紙期貨呢
甚至它的正價差
可以拉大到600多點以上
現在已經縮小到100多點
那代表已經有500點左右
蒸發掉了
所以現在如果你才想要
去放空台紙期貨
我不能說絕對沒有效果
但是有可能
相對是進場的位置跟價格
已經不是那麼樣的合宜了
這就是操作節奏的問題
所以我覺得其實資產配置
風險控管是平常就要做好的
那現在我反而會去做的事情
這個節奏也許跟
一些投資人想的不太一樣
我覺得應該是要把
相對抗跌的標的
此時此刻準備陸續換到
超跌跟大跌的標的
比方說我自己平常就有一些
類現金的部位
像是高息低波的ETF
或者是债券ETF
当然本来就已经所剩不多
但是还留下的部位
那本来就是属于资产配置的一环
那这些类限金的资产
我在等的是什么
其实就是这种时候
就是这种涨项
大跌的时候
我会准备来做买进
那其实事实上不久之前
我在季线这里
已经先进了第一批
也就是史上最大跌点那一天
那这个就是
我把低波跟债券变成现金
然后转换到市值型
跟主动式的台股ETF
因为我认为将来要反弹的时候
这些标的它的波动大
它的反弹的力道才会强
只不过进场之后
我们也会停看停一下
因为稍早聊到
不要叠就买
所以当我第一批进场之后
我发现弹不太上去
然后反而这一笔部位
我又有点被小套了
所以我也会先停看听一下
不急着去做第二批的加码
微软跟你怎么时候
会做第二批的加码
其实买进就要看讯号
那我认为如果是
以大盘的角度来看的话
当然台币要指扁回升
然后韩国股市费城半导体指数
它也必须要出现一个
强而有力的关键KBOX
比如说带量的长虹
那再来就是
我可能会去看一下
我们先前比较弱势的
一些主流族群
有没有开始出现
融资清干净之后的
率先直跌反弹
所以今天的跌跌不休
在基本面上面
因为外资或是内资
其实都没有出现明显
什么下修EPS什么的
所以基本面应该是真的问题不大
现在考验的就是筹码面
什么时候恢复归对
对不对
所以第二笔的加码
要等市场质问
然后所以这边的话
刚刚提到了
外资最近有微幅条件
例如国具 旺系
台光店 台达店
微服调降他们的目标价
我们要担心吗
其实外资真的是很抢戏
因为外资的报告往往都是
媒体报道跟市场一般投资人
大家会去追逐的重点
不过其实一篇报告
不能是说
完全把它当圣经一样膜拜
但也不要把它当垃圾
或者说好像是一个阴谋
直接就丢到垃圾桶资源回收了
其实我觉得还是要
从四个面向客观来看
第一件事情
刚刚提到目标价
最简单来看
目标价怎么来
就是预估的EPS乘上本地比
那通常大家拿到报告
大概就是迫不及待
先找到目标价在哪里
只看目标价
左上角
就把它记住了
但是我通常问投资人说
你知不知道联发科的
最高目标价知道1万元
对 卖格里
1万元
那你知不知道
联发科预估EPS呢
可能大部分人就不记得了
为什么就表示说
大家只去計目標價
但事實上目標價
只是最後一個數字的參考
那關鍵還是來自於
預估EPS跟本益比
那尤其重點是EPS
那你要知道就是
它的EPS是不是符合
比如說下半年比上半年好
那明年會比今年好
這個趨勢才是重點
那更進步來講
如果那些原文報告
AI有幫你翻譯好
你願意讀下去的話
其實要看清楚是
它對於整個產業的預估
它对于整个量产的进度
或者它对于
它未来的产能扩增的计划
这些相关的基本面的细节
它最后才会向拼图
一块一块的拼起来
那个所谓的目标价
我记得林发科高盛吧
有说2028年要赚到EPS400元
这个我们也好难判断
因为现在就赚6、70块而已
对
所以这个我们就直接来看
第四个关键就是要跟大家讲
根据两年后的获利
来预估的目标价
你絕對不要太迷信
兩年後
那現在已經算2026的下半年了
對 所以我覺得
如果是看到2028的上半年以前
還可以接受
那當然2027的參考價值
可信度絕對是更高的
因為現在確實應該要去反映
明年的獲利了
但是直接一口氣呢
已經拿望遠鏡去看到2028
甚至2029
老實說
我覺得就是看看就好
為什麼呢
大家試想任何一家上市櫃的公司
你問老闆兩年後猜測
他也編不出來
那再來就是
因為通常主流熱門股
它不會只有一家法輪出報告所以一定有可能很多家的法輪機構那這個時候大家真的不要只看你想看或只记你想记的目标价最高的或最低的
远远脱离市场公司
我会建议一律先忽略
你抓就是所谓我们讲大数法则
比较多数专业法人
大家不管是对EPS的共识
或对于目标价的共识
我觉得参考度会更高
那通常特别高跟特别低的
可能真的有时候就是
就是雨不惊人 死不休
或其他的目的了
那再來就是
如果有發現說
目標價被調高了
可是EPS沒有明顯的調高
甚至是完全沒有做任何調整
那這個有可能就是屬於一種
研究員的FORMAL情緒
因為研究員也是人嘛
人就有情緒
那它的FORMAL情緒是什麼呢
它怎麼調整
既然EPS沒動
那顯然就是動本益比
把本益比調高
那本益比這東西
本來就帶有主觀
到底要給30倍
還是31倍 還是35倍
其實這個其實有時候
研究員因為畢竟
他上一次的報告
有沒有到達他的目標價
這個會列為他們的KPI
所以他就會不斷不斷
去做一個目標價的調整
其實我們在看這些報告的時候
怎麼運用它
比方說在6月中旬的時候
尤其在17號到29號
這一段期間
南電就是出現多家法人
密集都在同步上修
那個時候
這些券商把目標價調高之後
到底有沒有引動市場買盤
有的
因為就在那一段期間
不僅是外資買
本土的投信也買
兩大法人都同步站在買方
再加上就是說
我們按照剛剛的邏輯
我們找出
比較符合市場共識的目標價
其實五大法人的目標價
平均來看是1275元
如果用中位數來排列
也是1275元
所以假設我們就搭配K線
這邊剛好整理過後
然後出現了帶量的紅K
所以這一根6月23號的突破的K棒
它的高點就是945元
假設我們就用了當天最高點進場
那通常我們會去做一個盤算
就是報酬風險比是不是大於3倍
如果超過3倍
我覺得這會是一比值得交易的投資
那潛在握力空間大概就是35%
那下檔我們就以當天進場的
這一根關鍵K棒的低點
当作防守点867
所以如果真的跌破
那我就停损
那下档风险8%以内
所以它的报酬风险比呢
这样一除就是4.38倍
那其实已经很明显超过3倍
所以我觉得这个就会是一笔呢
可以考虑进场的交易
好 大家要学起来
虽然今天的气氛不是太好
但是一旦之后恢复上行的时候
这就是非常有用的参考方式
好 然后刚刚也有提到
这个报酬率也许比胜率更重要
这个有的
這可以討論很久
到底是要高勝率還是高報酬率
絕對是要報酬率
兩位是一樣想法嗎
是的
我跟兩個想法不一樣
我都覺得好像要高勝率
賺少一點沒關係
因為以棒球比賽來講
打安打數比較多的
最後不一定是贏家
是計分板上得分比較多的隊伍
他才會是贏家
得分就是報酬率
因為你有可能只打一隻安打
一隻滿貫全雷達
蠻貫捲雷達 沒錯
兩位做動能的
原來想法是一致的
沒錯
謝謝威嚴哥
跟隨跟隨
雖然今天綠燈比較多
可是威嚴哥反而來教我們
如果今天又恢復到多頭上行
有很多的股票開始出現漲停板了
因為你在等這個
你現在把現金換出來
就是為了等這件事
那我們要怎麼樣找到
對的操作心法
因為往往一反彈
也可能會刷一排紅燈
其实所有的标股
不管是你曾经参与过
或者是只是
以前有听闻过的
我希望大家
在行情震荡的时候
都回头去看一看
做个功课
你会发现一件事情
所有的标股
它在启动表态的第一天
99%都是涨停板
都是涨停板标态
所以涨停板就是
标股的起手势
不过逻辑很重要
涨停的股票
后面不一定变标股
有些它就是只有
一日或一日半的行情
但是每一個能夠波段大漲
漲五成八成甚至翻倍的
它的前面開始的第一天
99%都是漲停
所以呢
我們一定要先好好研究
同樣是買漲停
那後面誰比較有機會
變成是波段標股
這就是我的闖紅燈心法
所以不要認為漲停不能買
如果後面有10根
第一根你要好好把握
第二根你也要認真研究
第三根以后才要开始稍微停看厅
那基本上第一件事情很重要
有族群性的是最好的
第二个其实买涨停就是要找起涨点
它不是要让你买在低点
要跳脱这个迷思
低点不重要
对
那再来特别重要的是
同样是今天涨停版的股票
那我会按照涨停的时间先后
分成早盘 盘中跟尾盘
那我定义9点半以前是早盘
1点以后是尾盘
介于这中间都是盘中涨停
那優先選擇的
最好的選擇就是漲停
為什麼
大家想想看
如果今天有碰到漲停
結果賣壓排山倒海而來
被敲開了
最後守不住了
那今天收盤
要嘛變成一個
流長長上一線
很醜的K棒
要嘛甚至變成
開高走低的黑K
這種形態
真正做順勢交易的人
都不喜歡
所以如果你
九點就把它拉到漲停去
你一定要讓它
鎖住漲停
那接下来四个多小时
所有的卖单
我照单全收
所以这样的一个阻力
它的心态是非常积极
而且它的财力跟手臂
是很粗的
那再来我认为就是
看位阶跟形态
底部发动的
当然是最好的
其次呢
因为当然一档
长多的标股
中间一定会有休息
跟换手整理
所以中继整理完的
是给你第二次
去研究它
切入它的机会
那当然呢
已经走到相对高档
才做噴出的
反而要小心高檔利捷
这时候的高檔
你可能配合
是不是利多进出
或者说技术面的指标
它是不是KD的日线周线
全部都在高檔了
这个时候反而要小心
我们就用实际的例子
来帮大家看对不对
国际前面真的就是
所谓的闯灯概念
后面就闯绿灯概念
接下来什么时候可以
去掌握它的反弹
或者说逢低加码
我觉得就看
什么时候它能够再次的亮红灯
亮红灯
不过我想见网之来
我们可以先看
你看在左边
这边一开始就是底部的涨停
这里爆大量之后
接着隔一天又涨停
去越过大量高点
换手后整整涨停
这里短暂做拉回之后
又出现了中继整理之后的喷出涨停
然后又连续的涨停
但是到了这里之后
就高档喷出涨停
如果以这个高档喷出涨停
跟过去相比
除了当然
技術面的指標已經在高點之外
大家會發現前面所有的漲停
它出現之後
那個低點從來沒被跌破
漲停的低點都沒有跌破過
但是這裡這一根高檔噴出漲停之後
當然當下我們不知道是不是結束了
隔天還創了一個新高
但是收黑1K
再隔一天的時候
這個低點就破了漲停低點了
慣性確實改變了
剛剛有特別提到投信
因為我兩個也帶過投信
可是投信
我们现在觉得怪怪的
他们也是一个套牢的状态
可是可能我们投资人
又一直加码投信的ETF
所以他们好像不得不买
有没有问题呢
其实如果以投信来说
当然最重要还是在于
基本面趋势的研究跟掌握
所以一般来说
如果基本面它很笃定
很有把握的话
它确实不一定说
每一档个股跌了两成
它就会去做停损
只要有写报告的依据的话
那它可以去捍衛它的持股
所以我想最近很多人想知道说
像国具981A到现在为止都没有卖
是怎么回事
那我个人推敲
应该比较可能就是
它认为被动元件
尤其是像龙头国具
因为MLCC的涨价是货真价实
那营收毛利也确实都有向上提升
只是说可能在操作
有时候毕竟经理人
也不是每两个股
那节奏都完美
高点如果没有跑
但是这波下沙的又急又快
那可能他认为跌到这里
也没有必要进步追砍
所以我才会提到
接下来如果真的
整个被动员线资金有回容
然后流动性变好
开始做反弹的时候
我觉得比方说
弹了两成三成之后
那个位阶跟时间点
可能才是真正关键
因为那个时候
有可能投信经营人
才会有进步的动作
那当然这一段期间
我觉得投信当然还是持续
有在台股去做一些
封低进场的布局
那连续买超的个股也不少
那特别就是
我以这个买超金额来做观察
7月份到现在为止
其实像南亚 台积电 南电等等
这些个股呢
他们真的都是砸了
两三百亿持续来做加码
所以我觉得当这一波
如果慢慢的稳定之后
大家想要搭个投信顺风车的话
你可以去找寻
投信真的是重仓布局
而且现在股价可能因为
无差别下沙
它暂时跌破了投信的成本
那我们可以去留意这些个股
至少代表这些公司
如果你对它所处的产业
或它的财报看不太懂
投信一定比大家懂
那有研究过
基本面至少没有太大的问题
那接下来就是看
什么时候在操作的点位上
是比较适合介入
好 所以我们这边有来举例子
像欣欣
不过这个真的好难操作
不是涨停就是跌停
因为最近的波动真的太大了
但投信对它是不离不弃的
对 那基本上已经
就是跌到投信的成本下
而且还差了有一段了
所以我觉得是将来
除非真的是投信
将来反弹上去
它想要做减码或停损
否则来看的话
我觉得现在你绝对是应该
要偏向站在买方来做观察
那我认为
既然它都已经所谓的
破月线季线了
投信都还是站在买方
显然真的是在看好
接下来的涨价的动能
会浮现在财报当中
那我觉得股价到目前为止
因为都没有一个
代量的长红K租线
对 所以基本上我觉得
这个会是空手朋友
你要先等待的第一个讯号
那第二个讯号来讲的话
如果能够站上五六级线
而且配合五六级线往上
这会是第二个讯号
那第三个讯号
我会去观察就是
月线跟季线重新集结之后
两条线都泛样往上
所以换句话说
如果真的要切入的投资朋友
我觉得至少要把资金
在这个时候再拆成三笔
分批进场
不要一次认为最低点到了
我就想要all in
那茂连的状况
我觉得会再好一些
因为它是先跌
然后也跌很深
但是也因为有酝酿了
前面一段的打底
现在反而是
月线已经开始往上
那季线还在往下
不过这两条线
应该不久之后
就会靠拢在一起了
那现在来看的话
因为今天也稍微有点出量
然后来挑战季线
所以慢慢来看的话
如果季线确认也能够
这个斜率转折往上
站上所有均线
其实是指日可待的
相對因為它已經是第一位階
投信也都集中在最近才開始買超
加上因為有公告了
六月份的EPS
大賺了六塊以上
所以我想算起來本益比也不高
這種個股大家也可以去做留意
好 今天也很謝謝威良哥
就是真的要分辨每一次股災
到底後面延續的是什麼
現在真的支撐我們的信仰
就是基本面延
要不然從形態來看
因為像你喜歡看形態
應該好多形態都走得失控吧
滿辛苦的
對啊
只能說滿辛苦的
所以我們一方面相信大人
對不對
相信頭性
一方面的話
我們也靜待所謂的軍縣
他們可能要做好手碼